[Music]
Welcome, welcome to the snack bus. I'm going to my mom's
bus. The customer's name is Yamada. My
name is Yamada. Well, I'm going to sit down over here
at Mama's Akemi. Hey, please excuse my neighbor.  Masu shochu is fine. That's all for now.
Getting involved with an unknown old man is the real pleasure of snack food. It's
Akemi-chan's job to talk about those funny stories,
isn't it? Saku's spirit, Saku's spirit, and why should I get involved?  You can't do it, you're
shooting, you're changing, you're developing your own ideas in a clever way. That's amazing,
Douglas Hamada. Douglas Hamada. Wait,
Douglas Hamada is about to fall. It's confusing
even with the increasing excitement. It
feels good to make the audience sing.
I think it's appropriate for a snack to ask you to do something
like that.I'm a master.Boys, stop representing men.I
mean, I didn't say earlier that I would get what the customers wanted to say, but
now I'm being dragged away.  I
don't remember what you said earlier.I
said it in a pose like that.